la situation épidémique et sanitaires en
ile de france nous préoccupent tout
particulièrement
même si la tendance est un peu moins
forte depuis quelques jours l'incident
de la circulation du virus il est élevé
350 mille trois cent cinquante quatre
pour cent mille habitants
ils sont enregistrées en moyenne chaque
semaine une incidence qui dépasse les
400 dans le val de marne et dans la
seine saint denis
notre inquiétude se porte
particulièrement sur les réanimations en
ile-de-france qui font face à une très
forte augmentation du nombre de patients
qu'ovide toutes les 12 minutes
un francilien nuitées jour est admis en
lits de réanimation en ile de france ce
soir 1080 patients ils sont pris en
charge presque le pic de la deuxième
vague
si le rythme continue à être le même
nous dépasserons les 1500 patients
qu'aux vide en réanimation en ile de
france à la fin du mois de mars ce qui
correspond à un seuil critique pour les
hôpitaux de cette région